hi guys sci-fi recapped here today I am
going to explain the film called I kill
Giants spoilers ahead watch out and stay
safe the movie opens up with a girl
looking over a dense forest near her
home she seems frightened as she senses
an ungodly presence despite this she
Ventures into the forest courageously
there she uses mushrooms gummy bear
jelly and sparkling dust to create a
potion she then uses it to Mark a
boundary between the forest and her town
before hiding behind a hill lo and
behold a branch-like hand appears and it
examines the potion as the girl watches
from a distance it's then revealed that
the girl is a young and strange high
schooler named Barbara Thorson she lives
with her brother Dave in support of
older sister Karen in a beachfront house
Barbara doesn't have any friends because
she is always lost in a fantasy world
inspired by her love of Dungeons and
Dragons she believes that Giants from
other worlds are going to attack her
hometown she spends her days crafting
weapons and traps to fend off the
monsters this includes suspending
leftover food on top of a pole facing
the sea and drawing strange symbols on
abandoned rail cars she sleeps in the
basement because she believes that a
giant lives on the first floor of her
house because of Barbara's strange
fantasies and behavior her brother Dave
doesn't like to spend time with her but
her elder sister Karen tries to be
considerate about her feelings and
beliefs however Karen rarely has time to
play with her because she works
full-time to support her younger
siblings by herself one day Barbara is
approached by a girl named Sophia at the
beach the latter reveals that she is an
exchange student from Leeds England and
she expresses interest in getting to
know barabra unfortunately our
protagonist is startled by her presence
and she leaves without talking much to
her the next day on the way to the
school Sophia again tries to speak to
Barbara but the latter again ignores her
later at school Barbara starts counting
strange signs she has made throughout
the school and it's then revealed that
the school psychologist Mrs Molly is
keeping an eye on her strange Behavior
later at lunch a group of girls led by
Taylor bully Barbara and demand money
from her irritated the latter bets on
the bully's hand this infuriates Taylor
and she grabs her by the collar however
before she could do anything further
barabra is summoned by Mrs Molly and
saved from the bully it turns out Mrs
Molly wants to talk to Barbara about her
peculiar Behavior but the girl walks out
saying she doesn't need therapy
afterwards Taylor again Corners Barbara
in the hallway and proceeds to beat her
although Barbara stands up to the bully
Sophia encounters the confrontation and
immediately alerts the principal who
suspends Taylor for a week seeing that
Sophia tried to help her Barbara finally
opens up to her and they return home
together they hang out by the beach
where Sophia commends her for standing
up to a bully like Taylor Barbara then
tells her the story of Giants and
firstly she tells her about the giant
who was born while before all the others
he was humongous in size but because he
was sad and lonely he took his own life
afterwards many Giants were generated
from his body there were some who lived
in snow while there were others who used
to kill many people at once thirdly some
Giants love to bathe in the blood of
children there are also harbingers
ghostly apparitions that warn people
whenever a giant is nearby lastly the
most dangerous Giants were the Titans
that could strike fear in humans just by
their voice listening to her stories
Sophia gets scared but Barbara continues
she mentions that she creates traps to
capture these Giants and kill them
Barbara also tells Sophia about a
Warhammer named kovasky which she keeps
in her pocket at all times she says that
the hammer is made of the bones of
Giants and she plans to kill all of them
with its help it's revealed that the
hammer can only be drawn out when its
need arises she has named the Warhammer
after a baseball player named Harry
kovlusky and his performance against the
New York Giants suddenly Barbara senses
the presence of mysterious beings and
starts heading towards the forest
worried Sophia tries to stop her but
Barbara advises her to maintain distance
from her as anyone who becomes close to
her ends up experiencing some form of
loss after reaching the forest Barbara
feels the presence of giants as she
tries to entrap them however the giant
manages to escape and she returns back
home she then hear strange noises coming
from upstairs Barbara nervously makes
her way up but when she sees a
frightening Apparition appear she gets
scared and runs back to the basement the
following day Barbara is again summoned
by Mrs Molly and this time the teacher
manages to get the girl to open up
Barbara tells her how she has saved the
town countless times and gives her a
file about the World of Giants
afterwards she and the other students
are taken for a baseball class however
strangely Barbara appears uncomfortable
with the game and she purposely gets
herself dismissed by talking Ridley to
the gym teacher later Barbara mistakenly
opens her pocket containing the
Warhammer this upsets her as the pocket
was only supposed to be opened when
needed taking it as an ominous sign she
immediately runs towards the forest
Sophia follows her and sees her looking
for Giants there she thinks that Barbara
is crazy and tries to tell her that
there's no such thing like giants but
our protagonist refuses to listen the
two girls then come across a dead Fawn
with its abdomen cut open Barbara
believes that the Fawn has been killed
by the giant while fear is horrified and
runs away the giant then finally reveals
itself and tells Barbara that she is
just a little girl who can never face
the giant by herself this frightens
Barbara and she runs away she goes to
Sophia's home and sets up a shield to
protect her from Giants later that night
Karen spends time with Barbara and the
two discuss their current lives the
following day Barbara again attends a
session with Mrs Molly who asks her
about what happened at the gym class
strangely the mere mention of baseball
makes Barbara emotional Mrs Molly
Comforts her and tells her that she can
talk to her about anything she asks her
what's going on with her brother sister
and mother but for some reason it makes
Barbara extremely upset and she slaps
Mrs Molly before running away Sophia
follows Barbara home but the little girl
is so indulged in her imaginations that
when the caring teacher tries to talk
with her she pushes her down Taylor and
her friends watch it go down and they
laugh as an embarrassed Sophia runs away
meanwhile Karen gets a call from Mrs
Molly and when Barbara returns home she
reprimands her for slapping the teacher
the next day Taylor provokes Sophia
against Barbara and convinces her to
reveal her Secrets Sophia agrees and
Promises to take her to the beach where
Barbara has set up her traps after
school meanwhile Barbara apologizes to
Mrs Molly for her actions and asks her
why she didn't get her expelled from
school Mrs Molly explains that she
didn't report her to the principal
because she genuinely wants to help her
the two then continue their session and
the girl explains that she hates Giants
because it takes everything that made
your life go away from you when asked
Barbara says she isn't afraid of giants
because she has kovalski and it can stop
death itself she then returns home and
encounters Taylor and her friends
destroying her traps enraged Barbara
takes out her Hammer to hit Taylor the
hammer is revealed to be made up of a
small piece of bone unfortunately the
bullies attack her and beat her
senseless later Barbara wakes up in her
old room upstairs with Sophia waiting
for her just outside taken aback she
yells at Sophia for bringing her
upstairs saying that there are giants
here this scare air Sophia and she again
runs away after a while Barbara hears
the sound of a giant coming from the
adjacent room scared she closes the door
and runs outside her house she goes to
Mrs Molly's house crying lamenting that
there's something wrong with her the
caring teacher tries to calm her down
but she then gets occupied with her
infant daughter seeing this Barbara
oddly comments that everyone including
Mrs Molly's baby is going to die before
running away from there following the
encounter Barbara stops going to school
and after two days Sophia and Mrs Molly
decide to pay her a visit they tell
Karen about Barbara not showing up to
school which stuns her Karen breaks down
as she speaks with Mrs Molly lamenting
that she has tried her best to look
after her siblings meanwhile Sophia goes
to Barbara's room in the basement there
she comes across a tape recording which
reveals that kovalski was very young
when he single-handedly helped his team
beat the New York Giants earning him the
nickname the Giant Killer Sophia also
finds a picture of Barbara's mother and
with a Giant's drawing taped over it
later she finds Barbara at a game store
the little girl isn't happy to see her
and she yells at Sophia for betraying
her she says that the entire town is now
in danger because she doesn't have
kovalski to stop the Giants Barbara then
leaves and proceeds to go back home but
she is confronted by some Giants
therefore she runs to the old train cars
but when the Giants again Corner her she
activates the signs and sets the Train
on fire as a result the forest Giants
are killed soon Sophie arrives and
Barbara tells her that she saved the
town by killing the Giants the following
day Barbara takes Revenge from Taylor by
hanging a skeleton from her skeleton
this makes the bully a laughing stock in
the school however when Mrs Molly tries
to confront Barbara she again runs away
soon a storm hits the town and Mrs Molly
calls Karen to confirm if Barbara got
home when she learns that the girl
hasn't reached home yet she goes looking
for her and eventually finds her in the
rain with a dead mouse it turns out she
wants to offer the mass to God in
exchange for kovalski Mrs Molly tells
her that none of this is real and she
needs to go home as her sick mother
wants to see her this makes Barbara
emotional and she again starts talking
about Giants it turns out that Barbara's
mother is suffering from cancer and
Barbara is having a hard time dealing
with this reality so she created this
fantasy about Giants to cope with her
pain after this she again runs away
meanwhile furious at Barbara Taylor goes
to the beach to destroy her secret
hideout when Sophia tries to stop her
Taylor pushes her down and runs away
injuring her in the process Barbara
eventually gets there and asks an
injured Sophia to take cover from the
rain Titan the biggest giant then
emerges from the sea and starts
attacking Barbara as the giant Rains
Down punches on her a ray of light
emerges from her pocket lo and behold
when Barbara opens it she finds the real
kovoski inside Barbara then challenges
the giant telling him that he can't hurt
her mother with one strike the little
girl brings down the Giant and claims
Victory however the injured giant then
tells her that he actually came to take
her not her mother it also adds that no
matter how much she tries she can't save
her mother the giant then lifts her in
his hand to take her but a furious
Barbara strikes it again as a result the
giant starts to sink in the water along
with Barbara while this is happening the
giant tells her that all things that
live in the world will die one day this
is why one must find joy in the living
while they have time and not fear the
end to deny this is to deny life the
giant then asks Barbara if she can
Embrace this fact hearing this the
little girl regains her Wilt alive again
and she swims back to the shore where
Sophia is waiting for her Barbara then
returns home and finally goes upstairs
and it turns out it's no one but her
sick mother sleeping in the room Mrs
Thorson is happy to finally see her
daughter and they tearfully Embrace each
other several months pass by and one day
Mrs Thorson passes away that night
Barbara hears the voice of someone
outside when she peeps through the
window she comes across the same giant
she defeated he tells her that he has
come to check up on her Barbara assures
him that she's all right and that she is
stronger than ever the movie ends as the
giant eventually leaves and Barbara goes
to sleep subscribe and hit that like
button to help our Channel grow turn the
notifications on so you won't miss any
of our new videos thanks for watching